Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
You're really tall today, huh?
I'm tall.
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Even if I was tall today.
Did you stretch a bit too hard?
Yeah, I did stretch quite a bit.
I was feeling a little sore after yesterday, but... But Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for our 54th episode!
BAU BAU!
Well, for Ruffians who are joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show, and it's held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
It's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
Ruffians first.
I wanted to say that was uncalled for, Moco-chan.
Great sneezy morning!
I was gonna apologize, but now I have to apologize for Moco-chan too.
Ruffians, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for the sister of mine.
And I'm also sorry because it seems like Pero kinda took over FUWAMOCO Morning the other day.
Are you doing okay, ruffians?
You know, especially because Moco-chan wasn't there at the pup talk for you.
Is that my fault now?
It's not your fault, but... We hope Pero wasn't too nasty.
You're traumatized.
Oh my gosh.
Pero's break was ruined.
Wait, your body's now... I don't know about that.
Well, it seems like he was there to try to teach us a lesson.
That FUWAMOCO Morning is too long, right?
You know, it is a short-format morning show after all.
Like I say every morning, right?
So, we're gonna have to shorten it down.
Otherwise, Pero will be back waaaay sooner than...
BAU BAU!
You're confused.
It's okay.
It's the morning.
You're still sleepy.
You don't know what's going on.
It's okay.
It's okay!
Hopefully we don't see Peron for a very long, long time now.
Yeah.
Why?
What?
There was a... Okay, what's sighting?
What did I just see, though?
Well, let's see where this ruffian spotted Pero.
De-den!
Oh!
There's Pero, that's him.
Oh gosh.
Ruffians, do we really need to give him any more attention than he deserves?
Trying to sniff your tires.
Is this some sort of hobby of Pero's?
Sounds kinda like it.
That's kind of a dangerous hobby you got there.
You know, being low to the ground, behind a car tire there.
Ruffians, definitely don't try this kind of thing, okay?
Yeah.
Pero is asking for trouble.
Well, hopefully everything worked out for this ruffian and you were able to use your car with no troubles afterwards.
Right?
Yeah.
No trouble.
BAU BAU!
Forget about that.
Forget about it.
I just wanna forget about it.
But next!
Ruffians!
RUFFIANS!
We're so happy because...
Lifetime Showtime!
FUWAMOCO!
I am with you in your song!
Got 300,000 views!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you!
We did it!
We shared lifetime showtime back with you!
During our debut, you were remembered by Ruffians!
And it's hit 300,000 views now!
Thank you so much for loving it!
And listening to it so much, Ruffians!
Thank you!
It really means so much to us.
Especially, you know, since before we talked about it, our big goal was maybe that it could hit 300,000 views one day, right?
And you know it!
We did it!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Wow, this song, my first showtime, it was written by another
I got it.
You are so many subscribers!
Has hit 3 million views!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
My first cover song.
Ruffians, you were pretty surprised, right?
When we said it.
With you at the end of our debut, right?
Right, because you listened to Lifetime so many times.
BAU BAU!
Right.
Right!
Right, you know.
We weren't able to see your reaction then, because you know we were busy running off to meet up with all the Advent members, you know, for a collab.
I'm still curious.
What were you feeling back then?
But thank you so much, ruffians, for still listening to a bunch.
It really means a lot to us.
And we hope that we can put a lot more effort and strength and power into putting more music
Thank you, ruffians!
Thank you!
Moco-chan, what kind of song would you like to sing next?
I don't know.
There's a lot of songs that I would like to sing.
Right?
Kaibutsu was kind of cool and powerful.
I sort of have fun sort of surprising the ruffians.
So I feel like I would like to do, maybe, maybe not very soon, but sometime I would like to do something that surprises you.
Surprises the ruffians.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
I don't really get it, but it's very happy!
The hololive reddit has hit over 1,000,000!
BAU BAU!
Can you believe it?
That's a lot of people, Ruffians.
A lot of people.
1,000,000.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for loving hololive.
No matter where you are on the internet, be it YouTube or Twitter or TikTok and Reddit.
Thank you!
Nice.
We hope, ruffians, that you'll continue to share your passion about hololive with everyone out there.
You know, we actually joined the hololive reddit recently, and we started posting every now and then, so if you see us there, don't be surprised.
You know, every now and then I see in the comments being like, is this the actual FUWAMOCO?
Yeah, I know it says BAU BAU.
It does.
But you know, we don't really know how Reddit works still, so...
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you, hololive fans!
Well, actually... On Monday.
Monday.
Monday was it.
Well, we asked for something from you, Ruffians.
And finally, we got our first big FUWAMOCO scoop!
Given to us by a Ruffian.
We have...
Cooney passed her driver's license exam!
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
The crunchy tail fight just passed her driver's license exam.
That's pretty cool.
Amazing.
Congratulations Cooney!
Congratulations!
I'm not envious.
You know, we've heard that those kind of things are pretty rough sometimes.
Ice-steaming great dogs!
We like to keep our paws on the ground, yeah.
On the ground, yeah.
On the
I'm getting nervous!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
There's been, I guess, a misunderstanding.
A bit of a misunderstanding.
Yeah.
Kind of a big misunderstanding.
Well, this time, you know, Fuwawa, she misunderstood something.
That's why it's a big misunderstanding, okay?
Guys, you see.
During our holo parade stream.
You know there was a minigame.
And up at the top right, it had the game controls written out.
You know, like this.
What do you think it's saying?
Well.
Fuwawa!
She understood it as W equals jump.
S equals space.
And thought that those were the buttons to control the character the entire time.
She thought that.
Until yesterday evening.
Ruffians, I only realized that it really doesn't make sense yesterday, but... You know W jump?
Okay, okay, okay.
The S space.
She wasn't thinking about it.
Now that I think about it, it makes my head hurt.
Yeah, my head hurt when you were saying it too.
Well, you know, it's just that keyboard controls are always weird for games, right?
So, it made sense to me at that moment, but... I guess not.
No.
Uh-uh.
Yeah.
It's an honest mistake.
That's kind of you.
Thank you.
But, well, I'll do my best next time to maybe understand the game's controls better.
You do need to.
It's important for me to be able to help you, Moco-chan.
But you don't.
I do!
Even yesterday you didn't want to help even though there was a controller.
I did!
You didn't take the controller in your own paws.
I took it.
You did after I yelled at you.
But yes, I'll do my best not to misunderstand and okay, ruffians!
BAU BAU!
The ruffians are so kind though.
It was just an honest mistake, alright?
Thank you for agreeing.
Moco-chan agrees.
Okay, next thing, next thing.
So, ruffians!
I know, I talked about, you know, going to sleep yesterday.
Only to happen.
Yeah, yeah, it happens.
Going to sleep happens.
But, I was woken up only an hour after going to sleep, right?
But, during that time, you know, I had a pretty cool dream!
So, I had a dream.
I don't know, this is so specific I feel.
I can see it!
Yes, okay, but it was drawn in a very nostalgic sort of, like, natsukashii style.
Maybe like pixel art or something like that.
It was very cute.
They were all very happy, okay?
Happy squirrels running together, pixelized.
Good wallpaper.
But, the thing is, is that when you looked at it from a different angle, you could see more into the world and more things, like stuff behind them in different angles.
So,
It was very detailed and I could see like different train lines behind them and buildings.
But then suddenly I could see Godzilla.
And then some buildings looked more like the main street, the Chuo Dori and Akihabara.
And then there was Mahoro from Mahoromatic.
It was a very immersive wallpaper experience.
Oh yeah.
And then I woke up.
And I didn't have the wallpaper.
Is there any way I can get a wallpaper like this now?
Is there fancy ones now?
Is nothing new like that?
Yes!
There's wallpapers like that now!
I don't know.
For now, our desktop wallpaper is still the Advent Debut Key Visual, which I'm very happy with.
But you know, if there's cool new wallpapers, I would like to see them.
Why?
Dreams can be flying high!
We follow your cursor?
That's pretty cool, but it's not as cool as seeing things at different angles high.
Could you imagine if the Advent Debut Key Visual, if we all followed the cursor?
Oh my gosh.
That would be cool.
I think that Moco-chan, that our wallpaper will probably never change.
Probably.
Yeah.
It's probably gonna be forever this.
Actually, I don't think so.
What?
Why?
Nevermind!
BAU BAU!
Well, that was an interesting dream, Moco-chan.
I think there's a...
I don't know.
Ruffians!
Let's check out some of your submissions.
Starting with the Doggie of the Day!
We have... De-den!
Why?
The Doggie of the Day today is me!
Not Fuwawa.
The Doggie of the Day is not Fuwawa.
It's me!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Mii is a bear.
I love those silly eyes.
Hey Moco-chan, do you think you could make the same face as Mii there?
Or BAU BAU-ing into a fan?
Ah, like a... Is that the sound Mii makes?
That's the sound of Mii in front of the fan.
That's how Mii BAU BAU-s.
Yes, in front of the fan!
You know when it's just quiet, but then you're in front of the fan and you're like...
And the AC is just right.
Like that!
I don't know, I think Mii-chan would probably be like BAU!
Wait, it's in the fan, right?
Moco-chan, it has to have the fan sound.
I can't do that!
BAU!
I don't know, I don't know.
Good reason.
Mii needs it.
Really.
Safety is number one.
Do we not want more singing?
Maybe not sometimes.
Yeah, but me, me is a very, very good friend.
Very good friend, yes.
BAU BAU!
Cute.
And more!
Today I went on a walk.
Walk?
Where did we go to?
We have de-den!
So cute!
It sort of looks like one of the winter romance movies.
The perfect day spot.
It'd be nice to go there one more time.
You can drink the apple cider.
Have lots of apple cider, not hot choco.
Not hot Mococo.
Not hot choco.
BAU BAU!
And then we have our question of the day.
We have... De-den!
Good morning, FUWAMOCO!
Good morning!
Quick question.
Since Pero is your demon dog master mentor.
Hi.
Mentor.
He's just a pet, really.
Please don't let him know, okay?
Would this mean that once you become masters yourself that you would transform into a form similar to Pero's squishy physique?
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO similar to Pero.
Hi!
Why would that ever happen?
Has anything given you that impression?
That we would transform into something so grotesque?
You know, Hale is Pero.
He's our mentor.
You know, Papa Puppy.
Does Papa Puppy look like Pero?
No, that would be awful.
You know, we have more than just two bones.
We're fluffy!
We're fuzzy!
Yeah.
Master Koi Dogs!
Master Koi Dogs FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Next, we have a very important stream coming up.
We do!
Our next stream is... De-den!
We're playing Play It Up together with all of Advent unit.
Right!
But more important, we have a very big announcement!
An announcement from all of us.
And we really want you to be there to hear it first, okay?
Okay!
You'll be there, right?
You'll be there!
It's gonna be fun!
It is!
But we're really, really excited to share this announcement with you!
Please be there, okay?
Pero already spoiled the announcement.
Huh?
What?
Oh my gosh, that's a big deal.
Wait, what?
What do you know?
Tell us.
Huh?
Do we have to get Mane-chan involved now?
You can't tell us!
Do we have to get Mane-chan involved?
Oh my gosh, this is gonna become a... A big... A big problem.
A cup of war.
Wow.
For ruffians that weren't there, that didn't have Pero spoil everything, you'll have to join us to find out too!
From FUWAMOCO and Nerissa and Shiori and people's mouths!
What does he know, huh?
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
Well, on Saturday we're gonna be going back to Super Mario Wonder after Ina-senpai's 3D birthday concert.
You haven't forgotten, right, Ruffians?
We have not.
But we're looking really, really forward to it.
And you know, it's been a little while, so we'll have a nice, sweet time playing together again.
No scary stuff.
Not becoming an elephant.
And that's all we've got.
Thank you so much for joining us today, Ruffians, for another FUWAMOCO Morning.
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our extra special Ruffians today!
Shion!
BAU BAU!
Mugetsu!
JellyPon!
BAU BAU!
Shabun.
Fatadetou.
BAU BAU!
Sagi.
Okamiku.
BAU BAU!
Egusomu.
Pettenkoi.
BAU BAU!
Crow live.
Skulls are done for you.
BAU BAU!
And to every other ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This is today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!